are you looking to eliminate the bad
foods in your diet so you can have
better overall health
and focus on more sustainable long-term
nutritional improvements
then youngevity's wellness 90 plan is
your answer
it's the perfect nutrition maintenance
solution whether you've been on one of
our weight loss programs
or just looking to make simple changes
to your diet in fact
many people who have been on our rev90
or keto90 programs
use this plan to maintain long-term
weight loss and healthy nutrition goals
part that really kicked in for me
was having a plan to follow youngevity's
wellness 90 pack is a combination of
products
that help you retain your success by
supporting healthy blood sugar
reducing cravings and continuing to burn
fat
the total meal replacement shake helps
to manage your appetite
while increasing energy with 24 grams of
protein
it's available in a nourishing chocolate
and vanilla flavor
we've included sweet ease in the
wellness 90 pack
with a formulation that includes
chromium and botanicals
that are known for helping to control
blood sugar levels
slender fx rev further supports your
weight loss by helping your body to
metabolize and burn fat
and we've included sleep eats with its
proprietary blend of herbs
to help you get the restful sleep that
is so crucial to successful weight loss
the wellness 90 pack helps you stay on
track and supports your long-term
healthy lifestyle
i didn't know healthy could be getting
in shape and being healthy could be so
fun
to learn more about wellness 90 and the
better health challenge
contact your youngevity associate or
visit ygybetterhealth.com